all right so you're 17 you've finally
deleted league of legends from your hard
drive and you've just downloaded valent
where do you go from here well believe
it or not most esports titles are not
primed for playing from the start you
need to optimize your settings if you
want the best chance at competing and
for that
most people look to the pros the fact is
for every game there are so called god
settings settings that the vast majority
of serious players all seem to have in
common you probably wonder why every
time you pop into a pro player stream
viewers are constantly spamming things
like exclamation point sends or
exclamation point res now these settings
can change from game to game setup to
setup and of course
player to player but we're here to help
you figure it out we're here to help you
make sure that you are getting the best
possible performance no matter what game
you're playing because when you're
playing a game and it is running smooth
as hell
chances are
so are you
[Applause]
all right so this week we've decided to
team up with amd to help you get your
favorite games running as cleanly as
possible whether it's hardware settings
or in-game settings we want to set you
up for success so you can continue to
pop heads in the server alright so as
i'm sure you all know when you load up
most games for the first time they
automatically detect what hardware
you're using and depending on how
scuffed your setup actually is
adjust your settings accordingly now
these settings take into account what
gpu or cpu you're using and even how
much ram you have in order to give you
the best possible image for your
hardware but the best picture doesn't
always mean the best performance and if
you're playing a game in 1440p or 4k and
it looks like a slideshow then
what's the point now when most people
start taking a game seriously they tend
to seek out certain settings that will
supposedly give them an advantage in the
server
even if it means making their game look
like
[ __ ] and the way that people tend to
start doing this is naturally to copy
pro players whether it's through their
streams or various websites all of their
settings are pretty easily accessible
but plugging in a pro player sensitivity
or resolution isn't going to suddenly
optimize your game perfectly not
everyone is running the exact same
hardware and your personal settings will
change game to game in valorant and cs
go specifically i would recommend
changing everything in your graphics
settings to the lowest possible option
and turning off any extra decorative
features like motion blur turn off
v-sync too because it might cause input
lag multi-threaded rendering can stay on
though this will allow the game to fully
make use of all the cores and video ram
in your cpu and gpu in some games like
rainbow six siege turning things like
shadows or lod all the way down actually
isn't a good idea in the case of shadows
you can lose them entirely and in the
case of lod you can kind of make the
perception of the hitboxes at all the
operators weird because they're going to
look all square and pixelated now colton
tells me that in apex you're going to
want to disable fov ability scaling to
ensure that your mouse movements remain
consistent while using certain legends
like octane and
i can't believe i'm about to give league
players a helping hand but in league of
legends turning on colorblind mode can
help a ton with visibility especially in
team fights we actually did a whole
episode just on colorblind gaming but
what i will tell you is that adjusting
certain settings can be beneficial for
everyone
actually how about i just get mr
actually knows what he's talking about
to explain to you since
y'all seem to like him better anyway
[ __ ] nerds and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
presented by amd
dimitri talks a big game but who do you
think he calls when he has a hardware
question
it it's me the answer's me settings are
quite literally everywhere not just in
the game you're playing but on all your
different pieces of hardware as well and
heaven forbid you're a streamer too but
when it comes to esports where you want
performance over fidelity the main thing
you're aiming to do is lessen the demand
on your computer's cpu and gpu your
first step for freeing up cpu resources
should be your out of game settings
things like your pc's power settings and
the cpu load from other programs running
at the same time as your game if you
want to get really nerdy you can even
dig into your motherboard's bios
settings and increase your cpu's clock
speed if you've ever seen pc nerds
posting about overclocking this is what
they're talking about now overclocking
will increase the amount of heat your
cpu generates and can even make it
unstable beyond a certain point so i
recommend doing plenty of research
before you go down this road when it
comes to in-game settings some can be
pretty straightforward lighting effects
and texture quality have a very obvious
impact on the fidelity versus
performance trade-off but what about the
settings that aren't so obvious take
ambient occlusion for example this
setting gives your scene a much more
life-like lighting calculating how much
ambient light should be reaching a
certain point in the scene while screen
space ambience occlusion doesn't tax
your cpu other more detailed
implementations will have a much higher
impact on your system what about another
slightly confusing setting like
anti-aliasing which is used to remove
jagged lines in a frame there are two
categories that aa settings can fall
into super sampling and post processing
super sampling essentially generates a
frame at a much higher resolution then
downscales that image to remove the
jagged edges post processing involves
analyzing the frame after it's already
rendered and blurring jagged edges on a
per-pixel basis generally taxing your
system a lot less there are an absurd
amount of four-letter acronyms for the
different kinds of aaa implementations
in different games and from different
graphics card manufacturers so instead
of me sitting here listing them all
you're gonna have to google whichever
acronym shows up in your game or gpu
settings and figure out which category
it's in and how large the impact on your
hardware's performance will be a solid
majority of in-game settings are likely
to impact your gpu performance since
it's the piece of hardware running all
those calculations and then spitting out
well it landscapes but it's not always
quite that simple your cpu also shares
some of this workload if you went out
and splashed on a brand new graphics
card and dropped it in your
five-year-old gaming rig you aren't
going to see the orders of magnitude
increase in graphics or frame rate you
were likely hoping for that's why it's
important to get a cpu and gpu of
roughly the same power to avoid
bottlenecks and get the maximum amount
of performance for your money sorry just
out of respect i want to make sure our
boy dimitri is keeping up with all this
pc talk
you nodding off there champ you need us
to play the simple falling off to help
wake you up a little bit
colton do me a favor
i am sending you some clips in discord
just check those out real quick
what clips
two on a
where did everybody go
why would he check that
why
why on earth would he check that in what
universe
does
because i live rent-free in your head
son
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about presented by amd
in fast-paced shooters like valorance cs
go and even rainbow six siege most
players value their fps above
well everything with high refresh rate
monitors becoming increasingly
affordable and accessible players are
now aiming for the highest possible
frames per second to keep up with the
refresh rate of their display that's why
most esports competitors make their game
look like [ __ ] minecraft they may
look like crap but they run way smoother
but when you're looking at all the
different settings in game sometimes it
just looks like gibberish like what the
hell is anisotropic filtering and what
do i do with it it's just a filter that
helps with the clarity of textures when
they appear at an angle relative to the
camera
come on dimitri well for that i went to
my boy robert over at amd throughout
this episode he's going to help us make
sure that we are getting the best
possible performance out of our hardware
you could kind of be
one of two different players you could
be the kind of player who's willing to
give up some frames per second because
you want the game to look better or you
can just crush all the game settings
down to minimum quality which raises
your frame rates sometimes by a lot
depending on what the game has
implemented and and some would even say
can give you a competitive advantage
because it makes uh enemy players stand
out a little better in the scene so you
first have to decide what kind of player
you want to be do you want better
graphics or do you want higher frame
rates it's really hard to to get both in
in the same game you'll want to at least
tune the settings such that
your frame rate is pretty consistent at
whatever refresh rate your monitor is so
you're going to need to look into that
you might have a 60 hertz monitor 120
hertz or heck even like 280 or 300 these
days and you'll want to try to dial in a
frame rate in the game that's very close
or beyond what your monitor can do and
that means you're always seeing
sort of the the latest most updated
information from the game which is
especially important for games like cs
go or other twitchy shooters now when
you go out and buy one of these
expensive ass monitors you want your
game to run smoothly because when the
frame rate from your graphics card
doesn't match up with your monitor's
refresh rate
you might run into some issues if you're
video card is producing more or less
frames than the monitor is updating its
own picture one is called tearing where
you have too many frames uh it's it's
the idea that all monitors refresh from
top to bottom they just do that over and
over and you can actually have two
frames on the display at the same time
and it produces this horizontal line in
your screen but to combat this issue amd
developed their own technology freesync
which is now widely used in gaming
monitors along with the nvidia
equivalent g-sync this allows your gpu
and monitor to update at the same time
fixing screen tearing altogether but us
cs players
we tend to just crank our frames up even
higher to solve the issue
isn't that right robert what many cs go
players do for example is just run the
frame rate so high and so fast
over 300 frames a second
that whatever tearing exists only lasts
for a very very short amount of time
uh and such that it may be imperceptible
to the human eye because it comes and
goes so quickly but there is one other
issue that can arise if your gpu and
your monitor aren't working in unison
with one another the other issue that
you can have is
to solve that tearing there is a
technology called vsync which makes the
graphics card wait to produce a new
frame to match the update rate of the
display it's not quite like freesync in
that it causes occasional stuttering if
you turn vsync on because that that
pause time that waiting
on the monitor and the gpu to agree to
an update
can can be random in time
and so that stuttering will make the
game feel
slow or choppy now from what colton told
me your cpu and gpu work together to
help pump out the most possible frames
manipulating texture data and other
in-game elements stored in your system's
ram and more importantly your gpu's
video ram or vram but not too long ago
cpus weren't able to make proper use of
a graphics card's memory some top
consumer-grade gpus now have up to 16
gigs of dedicated video ram imagine
paying all of that money for a brand new
graphics card and not even being able to
make full use of it amd saw this as a
massive problem but they also saw it as
an opportunity to change the way that
gpus and cpus communicate with each
other forever so late last year they
launched this thing called smart access
memory it allows a ryzen cpu and a
radeon graphics card
to communicate with the full width of
that graphics card's memory all at the
same time
and amd invented this technology we were
the first to bring this technology to
market that's essentially free
performance we developed this thing that
gives you extra performance in games
that was hidden by an arbitrary
limitation of the way cpus and graphics
cards had communicated for forever smart
access memory is quite literally a game
changer and even though it was initially
designed for amd users because it's
based on an open standard gamers who
continue to use intel and nvidia powered
products out of habit may be able to
make use of it in the future but lately
ryzen cpus have been king especially
when it comes to esports titles plenty
of games like counter-strike valorant
and even league of legends are all
heavily cpu-bound and it seems like just
about every top player or streamer is
picking up amd's 5950x to go alongside
their 30 90. you can get some pretty
impressive frames with these ryzen
processors ryzens are quite simply the
best on the market right now like dead
ass sponsorship aside whether or not
you're running them with a radeon
graphics card if you're just an everyday
gamer and or streamer
you can expect some pretty outstanding
performance we're very agnostic uh the
the point of our cpu business is to be
the best damn processor we can be for
every kind of gaming customer whether
they run
radeon hardware or or geforce or other
competitive offerings in the future we
we just want to be the best gaming cpu
and putting artificial limitations
on our chip
hurts us and it hurts gamers and we
really pride ourselves on the
interoperability of our hardware with
frankly competitive products so no
matter what your setup looks like these
so-called god settings apply to everyone
if you want to take your game to the
next level by boosting your frames then
lowering some of your settings is the
first step because even if your game
does look a little pixelated when it's
running smoothly
chances are you'll be able to pop heads
just like some of your favorite pros
graphics aren't everything
especially in esports
okay so for this week's episode we've
decided to team up with amd to get
help you catch your favorite game i've
engendered the weeb's demetrius you've
engendered the way bro the number of
people that comment on like your mouse
pad or wallpaper or whatever i don't
even know i don't even understand i
don't know idea bro like i've never even
watched naruto never mind like in
whatever the
hardcore weeb [ __ ] you're into